live chairman
thank you mrs fuller um good evening and
welcome to this northwestern area
planning committee meeting
uh today wednesday the 10th of february
2021
name is councillor maddie thompson i'm
the chairman of this committee
and while i think of it i'm looking
sideways so that i can read not staring
out of the window
the meeting is held under new issue
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april
in response to the covid19
pandemic there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all could i please ask everyone
present in the meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted when not
addressing the committee
this is to reduce background noise and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
uh you could keep your videos on if
that's possible
i appreciate some people have trouble
with the internet bandwidth but um
if you can that's a good thing um
where did i get to we're being hosted
remotely by conferencing software which
allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting whilst
being able to protect themselves and
others and
observe the government's knockdown
measures we're streaming this meeting
live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from points of order or
indicating that you must leave the
meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
now may i ask officers taking part
to introduce themselves so we'll start
with mr lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
lead specialist place and chief planning
officer morton district council thank
you
thank you mr lee mr johnson
good evening members my name is michael
johnson i'm the lead specialist
development management
thank you thank you mr lawrence
members my name is derrick lawrence i'm
the interim
senior specialist for development
management
thank you sergeant
good evening members i'm julia sergeant
of specialist development management
thank you thank you mr parker haynes
good evening members i'm hayley
parker-haynes and i'm a senior case
worker in development management
thank you thank you and
good evening members i'm sophie marden
and i'm a caseworker for development
management
thank you and mrs fuller
good evening members um i'm katie fuller
i'm clark to this evening's committee
thank you are there any other officers
present who
are taking part in the meeting as
opposed to supporting it
okay i'll take that as a no uh so before
i call on the clerk to take the wrong
call of committee members can i ask
those councillors in attendance to
introduce themselves please
good evening chrissy morris in the house
thank you uh
right mrs fuller could you please take a
roll call of members to confirm who is
in attendance thank you
yes chairman starting
with councillor durham please
uh present thank you
councillor mrs fleming president katie
thank you
thank you councillor jarvis
president casey chairman welcome members
thank you
councillor keys
good evening cody good evening chairman
good evening aren't presence
counsellor morley
no councillor siddal
good evening katie president good
evening
councillor mrs thompson here thank you
i'm just going to send a quick message
to
councillor morley okay
counselor mr why someone else could
uh miss white is quite likely to be late
she often is she has difficulty with
getting back for six o'clock meeting so
um could you mark her as apologies and
then um
i don't know we are rather in the back
of beyond both of us
um councillor siddall yeah did you want
to say something now
i i do actually um what i would prefer
in future if councillors aren't going to
be present that they write formally
to the clerk and to the committee clerks
rather than it being through
the chairman of the committee that is
not following the correct constitution
so i in future could we please ensure
that any apologies for absence are done
in a formal way
and not the chairman saying that they're
possibly going to be here
and possibly going to be late because
that not is not correct procedure thank
you
well they're not apologies if they're
possibly going to be late
it is normal to send your apologies to
the chairman of the committee
uh yes you're right people know in
advance they should inform the
committee clerks but very often they
don't know in advance
so obviously i will pass that on thank
you
so therefore so therefore your your
statements
are not valid chairman so that's what
i'm trying to say
i will think about that a statement that
someone may be late
as far as i'm concerned is valid but
let's move on um i think we've rather
covered item two which is the apologies
for absence we haven't actually
it says he's trying it says he's got a
password it's just going round and round
in circles i don't know whether anybody
can help him from i.t
yes someone in the background there
please help councillor morley
uh because he's trying to attend he
hasn't given his apologies
because he isn't trying to apologize
he's trying to attend
uh thank you right item three minutes of
13th of january
it's recommended the minutes of the
meeting held on 13th of january
2021 found on pages 7 to 16 were
approved as a true and accurate record
i said move if you wish to second that
motion please on your
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
somebody anybody seconded
thank you councillor if any member
wishes to raise any matter of accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
okay um mrs fuller can you advise if
there is anyone to speak i'm not seeing
any hands
thank you chairman uh yeah there is a
matter of accuracy
on page eight in terms of the sequencing
of the minutes they're incorrect
if we look at the if you look at the
recording counselor durham
did not advise the committee after the
discussion
and after the debate councillor durham
advised the committee
about the possibility that if we don't
approve it
it might be contrary to the ldp
before the debate took place
so therefore because of councillor
dharam's statement
i am concerned about his opinion about
that particular
application however the sequencing
needs to be changed if the clients need
to look at the recording they can do so
but councillor durham advised the
committee before
any lengthy debate took place thank you
okay tell us do you have a comment
do we assume that the recording is no i
i recall i made that
statement um after it became evident
that the um the
the decision so it was certainly at the
latter stages of the debate prior to
prior to the vote it wasn't uh it didn't
preempt
any of the any of the debate but that's
as i recall it i don't know if any other
members
um uh feel wrong if we do
um if we do agree the minutes it'll be
subject to
committee clerks checking that council
jarvis
so if i actually i've got two points to
raise but they
they were just coming up later on the
next page but
with regards to that point that council
siddhas raised i do recall
that uh council durham spoke first
because i called the application in i
was a little bit surprised not to speak
first so
i think uh i think counselor durham did
speak first on that application i do
recall that i don't know if that helps
chairman
um presumably i had put the
recommendation at that point if i hadn't
i obviously shouldn't um
the clerk can look at that and perhaps
rectify the minutes um
we will absolutely do that the recording
um tells us what we need to know
so oh sorry one of my screens
disappeared um yeah we'll rely on the
recording for that thank you gentlemen
uh did you have another point counselor
jarvis
they're very small points but if i may
just draw them to your attention that
they're sort of really
uh just wording errors on page
213 or page nine depending on what
you're looking at
at the top it refers to say section 171
it refers to an uh fourth line down
improvement in the visual impact
overweighed the harm i'm sure that's
meant to say outweighed
unless that's a terminology i'm not
familiar with um that should say
outweighed um i would think so yes
okay and and the only other point is
again a very small point but
you know if you want to get these
correct is on page
page four fourteen or two one eight
depending on
your reference point section one seven
five
halfway down uh that page and it says a
number of reasons for approval were
discussed
and along with information provided by
the lead specialist place
obviously that's not not a very good
sentence
i suspect it's just the insertion of the
word and chairman if i might suggest
but you know nevertheless as it stands
it's obviously
not worded correctly nope okay
well i'm happy to accept those as if
anyone else objects is
objects to those changes now is the time
councillor syddle's point obviously i
think we need to go back to the
recording um
so those particular points aside can we
please agree those
minutes as julie said
can you just send no account ah you've
done it councilman jarvis i'm just going
to ask if that's a legacy hand
right then uh we will
that's agreed by a cent those minutes um
with those
those points aside declarations of
interest i have to read this bit i'm
gonna move it
uh to disclose the existence and nature
of any disposable peculiar
interests other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they're also required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
with council
of durham i'll see you first thank you
very much
chairman chairman um i have a
non-purunary interest as a member of
essex county council because they are
statutory consultees
in respect of several elements uh
uh relating to the agenda but i also
have a pecuniary interest in respect of
item five on the agenda
so i will be leaving the meeting at that
point
and and i trust somebody will text or
what's at me when it's ready
when i'm free to come back in but i will
be logging out thank you
we certainly will thank you
anyone else mrs fuller can you see
anyone else
no no there's no one else so um
in fact it's your time to retire mr um
councillor durham your hand is up is
that a legacy hand
it is a legacy hand but um see you later
thank you
okay see you soon because we are moving
on to
item five which is the warren golf club
old
london road wood and walter and
councillor darren's explained he has a
peculiary interest so he's left the
meeting
uh in a moment i will call on the
officer to present the item but members
i'm just
giving you a reminder if you wish to
speak please make it known by using the
hands up function
the sergeant could you present please
that is chairman just getting it up
hopefully you can all see that i can
thank you my planning permission
is sought within the warren estate for
additional tourism and interrelated
leisure development
comprising of 70 holiday lodges with
associated change of use of the land
within two areas of the site
alterations to the existing bunsen
clubhouse an extension to the bunsen car
park
and a new golf academy
so this is a location plan for the
application site which shows the war in
the state
within the parish of wood and water and
in a rural location
due to the scared the site the red line
can be quite hard to see on this plane
however the site extends to almost the
entire warring estate
there's 113 hectares
to the west of the application site is
wooden water common which is designated
as a special site of scientific interest
and parts of the application site itself
are also designated as local wildlife
sites
with areas also covered by a tree
preservation order
this slide provides an overview of the
proposal and the locations for each
element
within the northern part of the
application site is the bunsen clubhouse
an associated bungee downs golf course
which is
this area here thank you
to the south of the clubhouse across
three of the fairways commissioners
sought for 50 holiday lodges
permission is also sought for the
refurbishment and alterations to the
bunsen clubhouse
alongside an extension to the bunsen car
park
which is here more centrally within the
site
um is the location over here for 20
proposed holiday lodges
as well as the position for a new golf
academy building
which would be to the east of the main
one clubhouse just
shown here on the site the slide also
provides a good overview of the existing
facilities at the roman estate
which includes the main warren clubhouse
um
the associated 18-hole warren golf
course
and the herbage park holiday lodges
within the southeastern section of the
site
which is this area here and within this
section there is
the warren active which is a gym and
swimming pool complex
for use by the holiday lodges as well as
offering paid membership
as well as the bunsen down clubhouse
which again is in the northern section
and the associated bunsen golf course
and the badges
golf course this slide
shows an aerial view of the application
site and you can see the existing bunsen
clubhouse here
and the area to the south where the 50
holiday lodges are proposed
and an open area of grassland here which
is where the 20
lodges are proposed the gulf academy
building is proposed
just here at the edge of a driving range
this slide shows the site plan for the
50 holiday lodges
the bunsen clubhouse and the extension
to the car park
the existing vehicular access from
little beddo road would be retained
which is
shown here and the car park will be
extended to the south
in this area here the footprint at the
bunsey clubhouse itself would not change
as part of the proposed development
and the 50 holiday lodges are shown laid
out here to the south of the clubhouse
the land currently's undulating slopes
from the north west
in this area down to the south east
areas of trees
of landscaping as it's currently part of
the golf course
and it's got a well-maintained soft
landscape appearance
there's a public footpath flying along
the eastern boundary
here and to the west
of this section of the application site
is common lane which is also a public
footpath for the southwestern third of
its length
this site plan shows the 50 lodges set
off internal access roads
each would have parking for one or two
vehicles
as well as room for three meter deep
decking
to the rear of each unit all the main
access roads would be five meters wide
and permeable construction using
grass crate due to detention basins are
shown in the southwestern section of the
site as part of the surface water
drainage scheme
it's stated of any application that the
50 lodges
would be a fairly orientated short break
holiday park
to be used year round
[Music]
this plan shows the landscape strategy
for this section of the site with new
tree and shrub planting
proposed to site boundaries as well as
within the site
this is the site plan for the 20 holiday
lodges and the golf academy
the 20 holiday lodges would be
positioned
as i said earlier and they're more
essentially within the warren estate
to eastwood dwelling known as wayside
which is a non-designated heritage asset
it's currently rough grassland boarded
to three sides by existing trees and
hedgerows
and it's open to the south only which is
a tree-lined internal
access road within the warwin estate and
also a public footpath
again these lodges set around internal
access mode
with both all have decking and parking
for one vehicle
the supporting information also states
this lodge would also have a two-person
hot tub each um and it states that the
lodges would be for adults only
however this is not something that could
be controlled for a planning condition
again they're to be used round for
holiday short term purposes only
the golf academy is shown to the eastern
mem1 clubhouse
and to the rear of an existing bout of
trees
this is the landscape strategy for both
the 20 lodges and the golf academy sites
again
additional planting is proposed to both
areas
now whilst the holiday lodges would fall
within the statutory definition of a
caravan
indicative plans for four bedroom lodge
and a two-bedroom lodge have been
submitted
and the application states that the 50
lodges proposed to the south of the
bunsey clubhouse would be finished with
black timber weatherboarding
and the 20 to the east of wayside would
be finished with natural timber cladding
the finish is something that could be
dealt with for condition
if necessary that's a 20 bit
20 20 a two bedroom lodge
this plan shows the existing site plan
of the bundy clubhouse
its footprint wouldn't alter as part of
the proposal although it would get a
canopy
to the front elevation this is the
existing roof plan
um at present the rear of the clubhouse
comprises two
relatively dilapidated barn style
sections which is this
area and here to show better in a few
slides
this is the existing floor pen there is
an existing small kitchen and dining
room facility
existing as well as a bar area and the
two rear
barn style sections are currently used
as a warehouse
and a shed storage area
this is the existing elevation showing
the main front
which is black timber weatherboarded
there's a single-story rendered
elevation which runs alongside little
baddow road to the north
and the rear and southern elevations
showing the barn
sections which will be replaced as part
of the proposal
so this is the proposed move plan
showing the two
project new projections to the rear um
they both finished in black weatherboard
to match the main front elevation this
is the proposed floor plan
showing the new rear projections forming
an
indoor activities hall and a new
92-seater restaurant
the existing kitchen area will be
reconfigured and the existing dining
room would become an activities
reception area
and the bar would become a cafe an
outside seating patio area associated
with a restaurant is also proposed to
the south of the building here
so these are the proposed elevations for
the clubhouse
keeping the same footprint with the
exception of the new front canopy which
you can see
here and the alterations would have a
brick print
and timber weatherboarding in black to
match the existing front elevation with
a tiled roof
and the existing single-story rendered
projection to the north would remain
as is so this slide
shows the site plan for the gulf academy
building
and these are the floor plans with
classrooms
and practice bays as well as small
office and kitchen facilities
and these are the proposed elevations
this part of the application site is a
fairly steep
slope and the building's part single
story in part two story to accommodate
this
the two-story element would be roughly
rectangular with a further single soy
projection to the south at first floor
level
it would be constructed with steel with
timber clad and timber cladding
and here's the roof planned for the golf
academy
the application has been supported by a
number of illustrative plans and
photographs which i'll
quickly go for as i give you quite a
good overview of the proposal
this is an illustrative bird's eye view
from the east
so you can see the 20 holiday lodges
this their location
the proposed golf academy the
50 holiday lodges the bunsey coal fundsy
clubhouse with the extended car park
here's some illustrative views of the 50
lodges you can show
see that they've been shown with the
black timber
cladding an illustr view of the
clubhouse with the projections here and
seating area
here's an illustrative view for the 20
lodges with a natural timber finish
and illustrative views of the golf
academy
these are site photographs i've taken
and these first ones show the bunsen
clubhouse
the top right shows the front elevation
and the bottom right the northern
elevation
which wouldn't essentially change as
part of the proposal other than a canopy
to the front
the top left and bottom left show the
existing um
via barn style projections that would be
replaced as part of the
development here's some views of the car
part which will be extended to the south
beyond the line of the conifers which
would have to be removed to facilitate
this
these photographs showed a relationship
of apple cottage and one and two hawkins
farm cottages
which are located along little battle
road with the bonsai site
so apple cottage is the white
riverboarded property here
and top right you can see the rear of
one and two hawkins farm cottages
the bottom photograph shows the
relationship between the existing bunsen
clubhouse
and apple cottage and their closed
replacement rear projections would
be in the same location same footprint
these shows um views across the site
where the 50 lodges are proposed
so at the top left i'm standing
just south of the clubhouse looking down
the site then top right i'm looking
from looking to the northwest corner
from the southeast corner so
one of the lowest parts of the site and
the other two reviews looking
directly across the site so you can see
there are areas of trees
it is well landscaped but also open
obviously in the fairways
these are views from little better road
taken towards the site for 50 lodges
taken in winter with the trees obviously
lost their leaves and you can see that
views into the site are
possible these are views from common
lane
towards the site for the 50 lodges
and here we've got views of the site for
the 20 lodges
and you can see the bottom left there's
the
public footpath and the internal access
road
and bottom right is a picture of wayside
which is a non-designated heritage asset
and the top left shows from within the
area for the 20 lodges looking
towards wayside
and some photographs of the golf academy
location
and looking east from the gulf academy
and then looking west back
at where it would be positioned and then
a view looking
right further west towards the warren
club house
i also went and looked at the existing
herberg
lodge park and there's a photograph
there the
warren active which is the swimming pool
and gym as well as existing lodges
within the wider estate
so that's an overview of the proposal
and the different elements that it
includes
the application states it's the aim of
the warren estate to build a new and
unique
short break holiday and leisure
destination for morden
with the planning statement further
elaborating on this by stating
that the applicants wish to expand the
range of facilities by providing
activity-based short break similar to
the centre parks model
they consider there is a shortage of
this form of accommodation in the
district and the wider essex area
visitors will be able to take part in a
range of activities including golf
archery horse riding walking cycling and
in and around the royal estate the
application has been supported by a
number of reports and studies
and a key consideration for the
application in line with ldp policy e5
is demonstrating an identified need for
the new holiday lodges and as detailed
in the report
officers are of the view that the
tourism report submitted does not
sufficiently demonstrate a need for the
proposed type of holiday accommodation
in this area furthermore the
introduction of the proposed holiday
lodges across the two sections of the
application
site would introduce an incongruous and
visually harmful development which would
have an urbanising impact on the rural
character and appearance of the site
and erode much of the open nature of
these parts of the application site
the application also has a number of
adjacent residential dwellings
and it's considered that the
redevelopment of the bunsen clubhouse
and the use of the land to the south for
the 50 holiday lodges
would result in harm to the immunity of
the area through noise and disturbance
and would materially harm the immunity
of occupiers at the dwellings along
little baddow road
namely apple cottage and one and two
hawkins farm cottages
which were shown in the photographs and
environmental health
have raised an objection on this basis
the application site contained a number
of heritage assets
including grade 2 listed buildings
however the conservation officer has
raised concerns on the impact
on wayside which is a non-designated
heritage asset
again shown in the photographs and it's
considered that the proposal would cause
some harm to the setting of this asset
although that this would be limited
however given the need
that for the additional holiday units
has not been accepted and the harm to
the landscape that the development would
cause
it is considered that the public
benefits would not outweigh the limited
harm
and the proposal would therefore result
in unacceptable harm to this
heritage asset essex county council
highways have been consulted and have
raised no objection
subject conditions one condition they've
recommended
is the submission of a workplace travel
plan and monitoring fee
as it relates to the payment of monies
it's considered this would be best dealt
with for 106 legal agreement
the agent has agreed to the principle of
the condition
however in the absence of a completed
106 agreement
the impact of the proposal cannot be
fully mitigated
as the application site is located
within a rural setting with little to no
access to public transport
the workplace travel plan is considered
necessary to reduce the use of single
occupancy vehicles as much as practical
in relation to staff working at the
warren estate
so overall whilst it's acknowledged that
the proposal has the potential to
generate employment
and generate economic benefits through
job creation and increased spending
within the district and adjoining
districts
this is not considered to outweigh the
material harm that has been identified
and overall it is considered the
proposal would not represent sustainable
development
the recommendation is therefore one of
refusal for the reasons outlined in
section 8 of the main report
thank you chairman thank you i've got
your council jarvis but we have three
members of the public
to speak and and before that i should
just say that
we managed to get councillor morley into
the meeting unfortunately the
presentation had
had begun only just but it had begun so
i'm afraid he won't be able to vote on
this long
council um but i'm sure if you have any
observation to
certainly through to make them since you
have heard most of it
um so we turn first to mr robbie davis
who is a supporter
that's submission one um
are you ready can we just check we can
hear and see you mr davis
council thompson i don't believe mr
davis has joined us
did he not join us at all no right
okay um that being so then we will have
to move on to submission two which is
from
mr james rushton presumably councillor
rushton speaking for the parish council
uh mr rush councillor rushton can we
make sure we can hear and see you please
yes here i am there we go thank you
right um please
get yourself ready make yourself
comfortable you have two minutes from
when you start to speak and i am
pretty strict about that thank you i've
tested it
thank you thank you very much um wooden
water parish council
and 182 others mostly residents
consider the proposed development to be
unsustainable
for the following reasons it lays
outside of this arcadian village's
defined settlement boundary
and as such represents an inappropriate
development without
justification the application sites
play an important role in creating and
maintaining the intrinsic character and
tranquility of the rural setting
the development will destroy this
important setting affecting the western
end of the parish
there is no demonstrated or proven need
for holiday lodges or that any such
knowledges
lodges will be accepted under the go
active brand
given the facilities and their size
offered by the applicant
the lodges and associated infrastructure
will have an urbanizing impact
failing to protect the intrinsic
character beauty and tranquility of the
countryside
by intruding into it with a loss of high
value landscape
the development will materially harm the
immunity of the parish through noise
light
traffic and pollution and will directly
and adversely impact on the adjacent
properties and the wider
area occupancy levels potentially
equating with the parish population
are not reflected in consequential
vehicle movements
including those beyond arrival and
departure
impacting on road safety on local narrow
lanes without fall parts or lighting
the 20 unit site will at first adversely
affect the setting of the arts and
crafts building wayside
and that of the warren listed building
complex not mitigated by any benefit
the stated employment levels are
hypothetical and considered unrealistic
the stated financial benefit is
hypothetical not outweighing the
detrimental
and devastating effect on the
countryside
there is no perceivable benefit to the
community just a major adverse impact
and there is no ecstatic value to the
proposals
we strongly advert you to support your
entrepreneur's
recommendation and to refuse this
application on environmental and
sustainability grounds
as detailed in the nppf the ldp
and the bds and as stated in our
response objection
thank you council washington right i now
move to the applicant mr moran to read
out
um his their submission um again can we
just check that we can
see you and hear you mr moran
hello there hello there oh hello there
uh
right same for you please you know make
yourself comfortable get ready to begin
and you have two minutes from the moment
you start thank you
thank you and three years ago the warner
states
estate started work to develop a unique
holiday venue for the modern area
activity focused short rate destination
of the highest quality
based broadly on the center patch model
it has been designed to encourage adults
and children from all over the uk to
visit
we consulted widely and feedback was
unanimous moulding had nothing of this
nature
and there would be strong demands the
economics of modern are compelling
nearly 3 million per year into the local
economy from 17
increase in martin's annual stay and
visitor nights
resulting in a 97 full-time equivalent
jobs
in normal time this project would be
represented a huge
new contribution to the local economy
but with the coven 19 pandemic the
impact is greatly
magnified it will bring employment
opportunities and much
needed all-round custom to malden's
attractions
pops restaurants and shops our case
officers recommended refusal for reasons
we understandably refuse
we do not believe this economic benefit
has been given due waiting
or the concerns raised appropriately
appropriately considered against
detailing mitigating
presented we confirm these lodges will
remain in our full ownership but
licensed
to offer short break under the whole
season's proactive portfolio
and we accept occupancy conditions at
safeguard bursts
we don't any district council under
current are currently considering an
application that delivers an immediate
and immediate seven million pound
investment into the local tourist
economy
councillors councillors are mandated to
promote the interests of the community
and fundamental to this is a strong and
vibe vibrant economy
by granting permission for this
application tonight the committee will
demonstrate
they support established and reputable
local businesses
prepared to invest heavily in the modern
district
thank you thank you thank you mr moran
um right i'll put the recommendation um
which is that the planning application
for the warren golf club be refused for
the reasons detailed in section eight
i'm going to ask for a second there as
always with the proviso that this is
thank you
um thank you that's councillor jarvis
but this is for form's sake and
it does not oblige either of us to vote
um in that way um it is simply to get
something on the table to debate so
thank you council of jarvis
you had your hands up first and in fact
you called it in
although it would have had to come
anyway being a major application
so off your council jarvis
thank you jim um first of all i'd just
like to say um
in pre-covered times i did uh visit the
warren
i thought that was appropriate so i
could get a balanced view i've obviously
had the opportunity to
listen to john moran talk about the
advantages of the site
and i've obviously also attended a
number of parish meetings
and i've listened to a lot of local
parishioners uh talk about their
their concerns and you know of the 201
that have written in of course 90
of them were objecting so i've tried to
make myself as familiar as i can with
this application
it's a serious and somewhat complex
application if i could just break it
down and then give my
my sort of views on a few items for
consideration
um i mean there are various parts to it
there are clearly
two to two sets of lodges going up in
different parts
there's a clubhouse uh there's car park
impact and there's a golf academy
but i'm not going to focus too much on
my comments on the clubhouse
on the golf academy because i have to be
frank the
same square footage uh the clubhouse
that looks like an improvement to me
uh and the golf academy looks you know
i'm not going to focus my attention on
those um but i'm going to focus my
attention on the lodges
and i'm going to focus my attention on
the car parks that come with the lodges
uh i think first of all it has to be
said
that uh john moran and his team have
obviously
trying to trying to do something for the
benefit of the economy
and this is a good thing and i think the
count the officers report
recognizes that they are looking to
create new jobs it's
difficult to pin an exact number on that
with any precision
but i think the important point there is
that they do have to
establish a clear tourism need and it's
not
obvious uh from the documentation that
i've looked at or from the officers
report that they have actually done that
do we
is there a tourism need this is very
important e5 as you know
sharing um i think uh in
in going there and talking i'm i'm well
aware that
uh john ran his team are very focused on
uh
trying to protect the local wildlife
trying to put
mitigating factors in uh to uh
to sort of uh uh encourage wildlife
etcetera because
but essentially they are will end up
destroying an awful lot of
open field opal countryside so um
i think uh although some of their
measures you know must be noted and i'm
sure officers
have noted those and there are some of
the reports that councils may have seen
their red attached
support some of those measures i think
uh
on balance and this is very important of
course uh in weighing these things up
that you know this will have a huge
impact
on the on the loss of habitat uh locally
and this will this is a very large
development
70 lodges in all and this will cause
a big impact on modern water which is a
a very a village that is very much in
the country
uh a very much a sort of rural village
um
of sort of 500 people and 250 dwellings
so sticking uh clearly having 70 lodges
has a big impact you know if everyone's
got a car
they go into into the village this has a
big impact lately
i think the point's been mentioned by
the officers about the visual immunity
aspect
um some of the houses nearby some
some of the roads nearby the footpath
they will see
these lodges um and they're obviously a
loss of them there's a lot of
obviously a few holes on the golf course
four i believe um
so i think uh uh the other point which
has been mentioned of course
is um that this is like a center part so
i i think uh i don't think it's really
proven and i'd be
pleased to hear officers comments on
this that they have
uh all of the facilities that some of us
might think of
that the center parks would sort of have
you know i know they've got a swimming
pool in the gym
but they're there for the people who are
already there uh
in in the lodges that they've already
got whether they've really got the
facilities other than golf
to provide the sort of center park
initiative it's possibly questionable
and if they haven't where are those
people going to go
and the answer is they're going to be
traveling around into wood and water
possibly traveling to north and that
sort of thing that's a lot of traffic in
the rural area
so chairman um just to sort of conclude
i think the
impact on the rural character lots of
habitat
is a you know is a big issue the visual
immunity loss
is a big issue and i think there isn't a
proven need
with regards to the tourism and i think
those are aspects with that which i'd
like councillors
to consider thank you very much council
jarvis
uh i don't actually see any hands up so
if anyone would like to put a hand out
please do um mr lee can i
did you want to come back with any of
that counselor jarvis said you might
wish to make a comment but if you'd
rather say it to the end then please do
yeah that's not really anything to add
specifically so i'm happy to wait
thank you very much uh i didn't see who
was first councillor fleming or
councillor siddal
sorry i think it was council fleming
thank you council civil we'll go with
councillor flynn thank you very much
councillor plumbing thank you chair uh i
know this
area well um and i'm afraid for me
although i note the applicant's comments
about economic benefits
i'm afraid the for what i've read and
heard i'm afraid the harm
i feel would would outweigh the benefit
i'm afraid that's my thought at this
stage
thank you thank you councillors
thank you chairman uh yeah i can see the
benefit
in this development i can see the
benefit for the district
in this particular development and the
fact that it would bring new jobs and it
would bring tourism and it would bring
extra revenue to
the area so there is that positive
element to it
however um i really yeah on
on the balance of it and uh yeah the
overall weight in terms of the size of
it
and the complexity and how much there is
that then outweighs it and it's it's
going to have
too much of a detrimental impact in
terms of
the scope and the size and the intrusion
into the countryside
so yeah it turns
my big thing is is is really is its
scale yeah
so yeah in terms of its scale in terms
of its impact that's the thing that
that then sways me against the fact that
yeah we do need perhaps something like
this in the malden district
um but on this size in this particular
location
i don't think it's right thank you thank
you
um i don't see any other hands up i will
just
pop in my two penis i'm i've heard three
very
balanced arguments from all the three
members who have spoken
and this application is it's certainly
not all bad but it's
not all good either and i think
i'll grow the council of civil action i
think this might be a very good facility
but i
don't think you can uh wooden walt is
the right place to put it it
just does overwhelm the community there
for me
so if we have no one else to speak and i
see no other hands up
um i think i will
actually put the recommendation to
refuse to the vote so i've already
mentioned that councilman morley
unfortunate because he had problems
getting into the meeting can't vote
so um mrs fuller could you please take a
roll call of the rest of us i would do
this by a cent but
this is a big application and i'd rather
not there's not that many of us to ask
i think so we are
voting to refuse the application as
per the officer's recommendation
starting
with councillor mrs fleming please four
thank you councillor jarvis
four thank you katie thank you
councillor
keys four
councillor four thank you and councillor
mrs thompson
i'm for the recommendation too thank you
you're absolutely right i shouldn't let
you speak thank you very much
right i will move on in just a second
but could we please get
um get counselor darren back into the
meeting so that he doesn't miss the
beginning of the next one
did anyone message him
hmm
i messaged in chairman thank you
so
uh
[Music]
okay council zone is back in the meeting
and we can now go on so we're item six
on the agenda which is our second
planning application land adjacent to
either stone cottage back road tolston
darcy
um although in fact it is in the parish
of tolstoy
um thank you
good to see you thank you very much um
right this is found on pages 91 to 104
in a moment i'll call on the officer to
present the item
um we don't i think have anyone to speak
on this one
but members if you wish to speak please
make it known by using the hands up
function
within the meeting and i will come to
you in turn right miss parker haynes is
going to
present so if you go please
you chairman
planning permission is sought for the
conversion of the existing hay barn and
stable building into a residential
dwelling
minor external alterations are proposed
it should be noted that this application
is a resubmission of a previously
refused application 1901 two
seven seven full which was subsequently
dismissed at appeal based on the absence
of securing the necessary rams
contribution
this is the location plan
these are the existing and proposed
block plans
this is the existing floor plan
the proposed floor plan
these are the existing elevations
and the proposed elevations the external
alterations include increasing the
height of the ling2 roof on the northern
elevation
the addition of roof lights and the
replacement of external finishing
materials
this is explained further in section 3.1
of the officer's report
photographs of the existing building
the appropriate mitigation has been
secured as part of this application and
having taken
all relevant material considerations
into account it is considered that the
proposal would be acceptable
and is therefore recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you very much um before i put the
recommendation um can i just ask you
mr lee and you might want to pass it on
to another officer
um miss parker haynes just said that
this was
dismissed by the inspector on the
grounds of not having
the rams contribution agreed is that the
only reason
and the next question is is that sorted
out i presume it is
for you germany i can confirm that that
was the only reason for refusal um for
the
application being dismissed so they have
submitted
a unilateral admin to cake in with this
application
thank you thank you um so
that inspector was happy with the
agreement
the the principle of development
everything yeah as the officer
explains yet the appearance yeah i
appreciate that but not everyone's for
clarity
yeah exactly for everybody that's
interesting
acceptable in relation to location
appearance etc thank you
okay um well i'm actually
councillor morley and i are the board
members but councilman jones has
turned up first so i'll go to you
counselor java
thank you chairman uh you asked the
question one of the two questions i was
going to ask
and obviously officer has clearly
answered that question
uh that uh the inspector only commented
on rams
the only other question i uh if that is
the case the only other question i've um
got is uh could this is a development
which is a sort of barn conversion
outside of the ldp
uh and obviously there were a number of
reasons why why it was originally
objected to
uh by the council and by officers um i
just wondered if obviously
could sort of comment if uh irrespective
of what the
what the inspector said regarding rams
would he have a
different view on this application other
than that one point
oh i'll ask him mr million for you
chairman it's not my place to comment on
that i'm afraid you know the application
has got a recommendation of approval
based on the previous appeals
which is a significant material
consideration determination of this
application
thank you chairman thank you
thank you okay that that's the nearest
answer you're going to get
council jobs i absolutely understand the
position of the officers
they can only say what they can say um
i saw councillor morley next and then
key yes thank you karen yes i've
i've no i know the area of the site and
i've driven past it a few times and
the access and feasibility seems fine to
me thank you
thank you councillor keys
thank you um could i ever go back to the
pictures please the photographs of the
barn place
thank you harvey and did you say i'm
gonna make it higher
did i understand
through your chat yeah this aspect of
the pro the proposal will be
made higher that is shown here
so that not quite level with the roof
the level of the front bit as such
from what i can see on here
right yeah no that's um yeah i can see
where you're coming from just above the
drain pipe i'll tell you that's a drain
pipe was it in the middle of the top
left-hand pitcher
no yeah yeah no no that's some
um i'm a bit intrigued the same as some
councillor jarvis but anyway we
we can leave to be intrigued thank you
very much
well thank you i'll i'll have my little
turn last as i'm award member
um i'm gonna answer some of
the questions that i think counselor
jarvis wanted to have answered but
he couldn't i think i can only say the
inspectors are so independent
they don't even have to agree with each
other um
and sometimes you get decisions like
that but this is local government and it
doesn't have to make sense
well thank you members we have the um
recommended recommendation to approve on
the table julie seconded
um mrs fuller could we take a vote
please
apologize chairman i missed you seconded
the um proposal
i'm not sure you did dad actually bobby
just don't think you did
i thought i did um i'll second it
yeah i'm sure somebody did thank you
maybe i didn't in which case i apologize
i'll quit it now
oh god it's counseling second dude thank
you um
cats so we are voting for the officer's
recommendation of
approval starting with council
durham please f4
you mrs fleming oh
katie thank you thank you councillor
jarvis
paul thank you katie cue counselor keys
thank you councillor morley four
thank you councillor siddall four
thank you councillor mrs thompson cool
thank you that is seven for
none against and no abstentions thank
you so
either stone cottage has approval uh in
line with the officer's report and
recommendation so now we're moving on
again and this is going to be an
interesting one item seven on the agenda
which advanced adjacent to moscone's
farm chelmsford wrote pearly which we
did see
last time i will call on the officer in
a moment to present the item
a usual reminder about putting your hat
your notional hand up if you wish
to speak um so miss parker haynes could
you please
please present the report sir
thank you chairman
this application was bought before
members on the 13th of january
2021 whereby members resolved to grant
planning permission for the retention of
the existing dwelling house for the
following reason
since the determination of the last
planning application the council is no
longer
able to demonstrate a five-year housing
land supply this is considered to weigh
in favor of the proposed development
furthermore the previous reason for
refusal regarding private amenity space
has now been overcome
since the resolution of members on the
13th of january
an appeal decision has been received
which is considered to be a material
consideration in the determination of
this application
as stated within section 2.4 of the
officer's report it is considered that
any new and relevant material
consideration should be fully considered
by the decision maker prior to the
termination of an application this
includes when additional information is
made available in the period between an
area planning committee coming to a
resolution
and the decision notice being issued
taking this into account
is considered appropriate to
re-familiarize members with the
application
this is the location plan
this is the block plan
these are the floor plans and elevations
these are the elevations of the prior
approval scheme
photographs of the site the appeal
decision is considered to be relevant to
this application
as like this application it relates to
occupied dwellings which were allowed
under a prior approval application
however the dwellings were not carried
out in accordance with the plans as
approved as part of their prior approval
application
this is explained further in section 3.1
of the officer's report
the poignant points of the appeal and
their relevance to this application
are explained in great detail within
section 3.3 of the officer's report
the appeal is attached as appendix 2 of
the officers report
point 26 of the appeal confirms the
officer's view that the prior approval
application
for this application is no longer extend
and as such does not form a basis for
the principle of residential development
in this location
point 71 of the appeal provides further
clarification in relation to the purpose
of a prior approval application under
class queue
the principle of the development of the
site and the sustainability of the site
are not considerations
let alone material considerations under
a prior approval application and
therefore any prior approval application
does not
result in the principle of a residential
use of the site
or the sustainability of the site being
accepted
point 73 of the appeal confirms that due
to the development having not been
carried out in accordance with the plans
as approved by the
prior approval application the 2015
prior approval provides
no fallback position has no way and is
not a factor that weighs in favor of the
development
finally point 84 of the appeal discusses
the weight attributed to the council's
lack of a five-year housing land supply
whereby the inspectorate found that due
to the limited shortfall limited weight
should be afforded to this
this is particularly relevant
considering the weight attributed by
members to the council's inability to
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply in resolving to approve this
application
it is considered that the appeal
decision provides a material
consideration that should be afforded
significant weight in the determination
of this application
this appeal decision is considered to
provide further justification for the
refusal of this application
in line with the officer's recommended
reason for refusal
thank you chairman thank you
we do have the applicant to read the
submission at least i hope we do mr
strassen
okay good evening hold on a minute just
a moment i was expecting
mr strasson i'm not sure if that
it's a problem it does have to be
someone who's already written or
okay yeah he can read it that's fine
okay thank you
um two minutes from when you
begin mr strathearn and um please
as it's the second time around for this
application you have to restrict
yourself to
the new the new material under
consideration so thank you
there you go okay good evening and thank
you for giving me this opportunity to
speak
number one our application is a single
dwelling in a sustainable location that
is nearby to the site
of these five successful appeals between
2016 and 2019 the residential
development
long chunk was road pearly by contrast
the appeal
at mayfork which the officers referred
to consider it
of dwellings in a location that no
planning application nor appeal has
deemed sustainable since 2013
and which were turned down by
southeastern area planning committee
number two similar to other appeals for
dwellings on chelmsford road
the careful and sympathetic design of
our proposal does not cause harm to the
landscape character and many residents
have confirmed
this with their support we have restored
a formerly derek building
sympathetic and to the original bomb has
been retained the dwelling is within
ribbon of a similar
there's residential development and
therefore does not harm the character
and the appearance of the area by
contrast the mafia hill was
for newly constructed building and the
design of that
new building was characterized as strong
bold and prominent
all purdey number three all page local
amenities are accessible right on foot
by the implemented footpath just a 12
minute walk there's also a d2 bus route
hence
we will not have the heavily reliant on
car use by contrast may thought was
described as contacting
few or no services and decisions within
limited or no access to public transport
our application meets all the cats not
sorry number four outcome meets all the
council's requirements for parking space
garden size and
for previous provision cycle storage
this is unlike
the development at maple uh proposal
improvements to the appearance of the
former derrick building and is positive
addition to pearly village
that has no impact on character and
appearance
of the area and we respectively ask for
the community continue to support thank
you very much for listening
thank you i'm sorry that's on you but my
list said
mister i didn't want to do something
unconstitutional
render you irrelevant what a terrible
thing to do so i'm sorry you did very
well
okay um
right i have to put the recommendation
um
i was thinking i'm wondering when to
refer to
mr lee have you got any comment to make
at this camera
at this juncture about why this is back
why this
had to come back which i understand it
did um i think members would appreciate
an explanation and then i'll put the
recommendation thank you
thank you i'm happy to assist um
as members know an application must be
determined
with the development plan material
considerations indicate otherwise
and an application is not determined
until the decision notice goes out it
doesn't matter whether it's officers
members
the council determines the application
and legally an application is not
determined until
the decision notice goes out
if a new material consideration arises
then there needs to be consideration
whether that goes to the heart that
matters whether that looks at the
various points that could or would
potentially change an outcome
doesn't say it has to doesn't say it
definitely will but has the potential to
and if so legally the council as the
decision maker
needs to consider these um
what you'll see for example with a
delegated report which you wouldn't see
in the back office
would be that you know an officer may
well write a report
and have it checked by a team leader but
while it's sitting waiting for the
decision that is to
be determined a new letter comes in or
there's a new disappear decision we
would update that
report to take that into account before
issuing decision note as i said
sometimes they may affect
the decision sometimes they may not but
that is the correct process
and what happened in this instance was
that a decision notice for an appeal
came in after the application had been
to committee but before the decision
notes had been issued
that is a very similar form of
development
the only other application that we have
had
where a prior approval has been granted
they're not implemented then expired and
then come back to us
that i can think of is this other
application that we then
refused and the fact the agent or the
applicant highlighted it was a
southeast committee as i said it doesn't
matter it's the council
it's irrelevant to what chair it falls
within in that respect
but that is the council had received
something new
of a very similar form of development
and therefore it is a consideration
and what made it slightly even more of a
consideration in this instance is that
the similarities to the points that
formed the reason for approval
and how the inspector talked to them
points during his resolution of the uh
or determination of the appeal
um members obviously be
aware of example the south morgan relief
road application that went back to
members while a few months back i think
the summer of last year where
it had been granted a resolution for
approval by members
subject to um a certain number of
requirements in relation to the delivery
of a relief road
for a large number of house dwellings
the applicant
through the delivery of the 696 changed
how that was going to the funding was
going to be managed basically it's going
to be essex county council rather than
the applicant
that did not change the head to terms
did not change the times did not change
anything but
officers still considered that that was
a material situation that had changed
and therefore sent it back to committee
so this is it's not an unusual thing to
happen it's not a
something that's you know particularly
un clandestine or unusual but what it is
it's quite unusual i would say to have
it on something
on a small development because it's
almost unheard of to get an appeal
decision that relates so similarly to a
very
specific relatively new issue because as
members know
the prior approval is quite a new
process we haven't had a lot of them
so um particularly we obviously haven't
had ones that have been built
differently
so for that we're in a very much um the
salad days of such the case law and the
understanding of this
so it is a very unusual circumstance in
that where we find ourselves and why
it's come back
but it is the correct legal process that
members just need to be aware of it um
and as i said like even if to be honest
even if officers recommend this
application for approval at the last
committee
taking into account the appeal decision
it would still have been brought back to
members for redetermination because
the appeal decision is just so similar
in nature to
this decision or its application i hope
that's
not been too long-winded and i hope he's
given a fairly comprehensive explanation
because it isn't a simple question
thank you chairman thank you um actually
you anticipated my
next question which was well does this
ever happen with delegated decisions
that we never hear anything about and
obviously it does
um our counselor keys his hand up but i
am going to put the recommendation
first that the bonds adjacent to
moscone's farm chancellor
pearly be refused for the reasons as
detailed in the
section 8 of this report do i have a
second please
[Music]
okay right thank you councillor keys
i'll say again as always do for those
just tuning in um that that does not in
any way
oblige you to vote as you have did
because you haven't heard the debate yet
um right chairman sorry before um mr
lawrence did raise his hand i don't know
if he wanted to add something
sorry yeah
i just wanted to make the point that the
appeal decision actually came in the
very day after the planning committee
therefore bearing in mind that it was so
soon after that
officers felt it was incumbent upon them
that they had a duty
to ensure that members were aware of the
appeal decision so that's what i wanted
to add
that's why we brought it back that it
was so up to date and it came in
immediately following the meeting
thank you very much yeah i i do
understand actually if you put it in a
novel
you know no one would believe you but
these coincidences happen
um councillor fleming is in fact the
board member but counselor keys got his
hand up
first so council fleming would you like
to round up at the end or would you like
to go first
um no counselor keys can go first he's
had his hand up for a while
and they're not pleased and council keys
very very much councillor fleming but it
was ladies first through all that
um it's just uh thank you very much matt
lee but it might be me that what you
said was as clear as mud but i think
i've got the gist of
just as most of it come the end have we
got any
newer or more modern pictures of this
now because
their mothers looked a bit old or was it
just me thinking they were
an older picture no
yes for a new chair
and these were the most sorry these are
the most recent pictures provided by the
applicant
i don't believe it's changed much no no
you must pass it reasonably often is
that fair assumption
so does it look like it looks in the
pictures yes it does
thank you there you go please it looks
like it
it's not even been there very long yeah
well i know i know
as such where the place is um so
it's came back here is this likely to be
a regular occurrence do we think
with other applications or can't we say
that don't know
mr lee let's see chairman um
i would hope it's not a regular
occurrence and as i said
sorry cancel the keys if i wasn't
particularly clear
no no no it probably was me and i do put
my hand up it was quite a
very long response i hadn't really
thought of a formal response for it's
maybe i should have done because it
would have
been a bit logical for me to offer um as
i said the whole prior approval
process is relatively new um
so we've had a number we've had quite a
lot of them but you know
we've only had a certain quantum of them
and then to have a situation where we
have had somebody not build it in
accordance with approved plans then
resubmit and then for us to make a
decision
is obviously slightly different and
we're still forming our knowledge
base for these decisions and to then too
as um i think the chairman said you know
if you had it in a novel you wouldn't
believe it you know for it to come in
the next day
um you know i think that hopefully the
chances of this happening aren't too
common or too prevalent but
as decision makers and that's whether
it's officers or members we need to be
fully aware of the facts when coming to
a decision
to have a legally robust decision so if
these things continue to happen
um that is the case i think maybe for a
bit of clarity for comparison maybe a
bit pointless
where sometimes you see reports that
have been drafted
and committed before the end of the
neighbour expiry and the actual
recommendation in that instance is to
delegate to myself subject to no new
material considerations coming in
and if a neighbor raised the letter or
something sent in a letter that didn't
raise anything new
even if they raised similar points it
would be determined as is
but if they raised something new that
was mature new metal situation we'd have
to send it back to committee the next
month
so it's similar in that respect where we
have had them before and i'm not sure if
it's north west but
as a district over the six years i've
been here we have been in that situation
for
and that's something i'd say probably a
little bit more tangible as in members
experienced how it would compare
but generally i would hope that we don't
end up with these regularly happening
thank you chairman i have got you mr
johnson but um
mr lee i mean we're talking about a
cooper here but
a prior approval but in fact the
principle of bringing it back applies to
any
planning application i presume and
actually in 10 years of planning
applications i can only think of the one
example that you just mentioned that
happens so
it's not unheard of but it's not common
is it
right mr johnson and then we'll carry on
with the members please
yes thank you chairman uh again just to
underline some of the points here
um and what my colleague mr lee um
picked up about um the consideration of
this
material in between the resolution
and the issuing of the decision uh
what underlined our position as well as
the fact that
the cooper um had expired and the
development had taken place so therefore
it was not in accordance
in addition to that it also underlined
the fact that
the um
the the fact that there is no for that
position
also is in the sense that this is not a
site for a residential development that
would have been allowed in the first
place yeah
so on all counts there is no fallback
position
um had it not been for a cooper which
the
criteria is outside of our control if it
complies with the legislation
then it has to be allowed this goes
beyond
determinations that we would make
through our development plan
such as the settlement uh boundary
issues inside and outside
and issues of that case so part of
our bringing this um back to members
um it's also on the basis that had we
had this decision before it came to
members
this would have been included within the
report and would have supported
officer's position
on the fact that there is appeal
decision which is a material
consideration to be taken into account
so that's to support and and hopefully
the members to understand why this is in
front
of them to assist officers
recommendation this would have been with
you
had it come before it's just the case
that it just came afterwards
thank you chairman thank you uh right
i've got councillor fleming
and councillor siddal please counsel for
me
can't hear you you're muted
thank you chair um i think we're all
grateful to the officers for their
diligence in
bringing this uh back to us uh
however i'm not entirely sure i agree
with the
relevance of the old thorn appeal having
read it
i can see quite large differences
that seemed to be a rebuild if you like
um and also also on is quite a different
village to pearly and the sighting of
that appeal
is different you know reading the
inspectors words i'm not
entirely sure that i agree with the
relevance
of that appeal and
you know we heard from the applicant
about the appeal cases i think if
haley can bring up the location plan
again
holy do you have that miss parker haynes
yes sorry i'm on it thank you
thank you so if we can see the
uh houses opposite we've got tree lawn
thai meadow brook house
and then there's rudley lodge and rudely
oaks i think as i said before
if this had been brought to us ten years
ago
i probably would have agreed with the
officers uh recommendation
however because of the appeals across
the road there
the character of this area has changed
significantly
and um you know the uh the
inspector particularly i mean and these
were
appeals when we had a five-year land
supply
they're relatively recent i think it was
2019
maybe one of the officers can help me
with that i think
one was i believe at least one was some
were much older but some
i think one more i think there's sort of
two or three maybe
that were in 2019 where the inspector
ruled that they were in
a sustainable location and that there
was no harm to the area
so i mean i'm afraid that's where i
place my weight
with the inspectors decisions there
in very close proximity thank you that's
all i have to say for now
thank you thank you um
i think i only had councillor siddal's
hand out but i can't see him at
the moment yes i can council please
thank you thank you chairman uh i would
just like to
agree with what councillor fleming has
said this is a sustainable location
uh it is on a bus route it there are
other houses around
there are houses beat recently there's
been a house built over the road
on what used to be a nursery so there is
far more
uh development in this particular area
and therefore it is sustainable
i also question whether this is a
members meeting
because having four four officers
putting their point of view at this
meeting
i feel is untotally unnecessary and
is an overkill in terms of them trying
to get their message across to us
it does not require four officers
to present their case and i find that
questionable
well i'm the chairman and i don't
so there you go i find it perfectly
acceptable for the officers to bring
as many of their colleagues as they feel
they need to
um mr lee i see your hand up sorry about
that
thank you chairman just for a little bit
of clarity um
and just a comment on council fleming
made um
i totally acknowledged that the previous
or not previously the appeal decision
that we have
relates to an exceptionally large
potential amount of
built form but it goes to the heart the
matter
in the fact that it was not what was
approved and that's similar to this so
to a certain extent it doesn't
in planning terms my advice would be it
doesn't matter whether or not it is
a whole demolition rebuild or whether it
is just beyond
the prior approval process because as
soon as that happens
it crosses that line out of being able
to benefit from that
permission or anything like that so i
understand what council fleming
was saying but i'd just advise obviously
there is
it's almost like there's a line in the
sand once you step over it doesn't
matter
how far you've stepped over it that
would be my advice for the consideration
but
yeah you are right there is a
demonstrable difference in the level of
changes and
built forward amendments and stuff that
would be my advice to you just
and all members in the thought process
thank you chairman
thank you mr lee right i've got
councillor jarvis and then councillor
fleming would like to come back
but i'll leave her till the last of my
money
council jarvis thank you chairman um
i'll be brief i mean i'd just like to
thank officers uh of
clearly they were obligated to bring
this to our attention
uh thanks very much all four of them for
going through that
and giving us their view with regards to
materiality
which obviously all councillors will
take on board when they weigh up their
decision
but at the same time of course
councillors will also take on board
all of the other factors in this
specific application so
thank you to the officers for explaining
it service thank you chairman
thank you and councillor fleming i think
let's
wind up with uh with you thank you thank
you to
i just wanted to um go back to mr lee
because my understanding was that the
changes to the design were
minor changes to the fenestration is
that right i understood that correctly
um mr lee please or miss parker haynes
it may be more appropriate for [ __ ]
just call up the plans and go through
that
to certain sorry clarify though
as we're talking about the prior
approval as soon as you go beyond that
it just means that that couldn't be
implemented that so
it is like let me try and think how best
to
word this but i'll get count uh mrs
haynes to maybe take you through and
i'll
we've think about it and come back to
you okay
how are you doing there mr parker haynes
can you get the um
yes sorry chairman um
i know these things aren't instant we're
only just getting the hang of the
virtual thing then we'll probably have
to stop again
thank you so yeah the the changes from
the prior approval scheme include the
addition of the roof lights
and amendments to the positioning of
the openings um
which i think was to do with um the
practical design of the building
and i'd also just like to comment on the
appeals that have been mentioned
i think these relate to tree lawn brook
house
time meadow and sunnycot and
the most recent one that was allowed on
appeal was the 15th of march 2019 and
was in relation to thai meadow
and all of these properties do sit a
minimum of 190 metres closer to the
settlement boundary
and do benefit from um access to the
formalized footpath
tree lawn was determined prior to the
adoption of our
local development plan and um
brook house was for the consideration of
replacement dwellings
rather than new residential dwellings
okay right actually that helps thank you
very much
um frank uh councillor fleming you know
that that
that was very helpful um because yeah
that that sort of confirmed me because
just looking at
the old thorn inspector's comments
um he made great play he or she
um about the sort of the built form
and the fact that it you know they've
taken walls down and
it would it been a rebuild essentially
so
i see uh this application as being quite
different in that respect
also olson is a village with
few services pearly has everything there
um most weeks i can not happily not
leave the village it has everything
shop uh school nursery
there's a bus route there's a pub uh it
has everything
village hall so i see the two
cases as being quite quite different
thank you thank you well the obligation
was
to consider it not necessarily to agree
with it so
unless anyone else has a hand to pop up
and i'm not
seeing any um i think we will take the
recommendation to refuse to revoke
please
mrs fuller um so that's what we're
voting on the officer's recommendation
to refuse
um now actually before we go there i
have a question for mr lee because not
knowing which way this is going to go
i'm going to need some advice on what we
do
what we might need to do next so if you
could be thinking about that mr lee and
mrs fuller could you go ahead with the
vote please
yes chairman so we are voting for the
officer's
recommendation of refusal starting with
councillor durham please
um on balance and it is balanced
very delicately but i'm going to um
agree the officer's recommendation for
this one thank you
councillor mrs fleming against katie
thank you
thank you councillor jarvis
against thank you katie you counselor
keys
against foreign
councillor mrs thompson
um i'm still for the recommendation uh
as i was last time to be fair so
thank you oh what was the what's the
scores on that please
thank you so the recommendation to
refuse
for so mr lee i need some advice please
obviously i need a
um can we re-run the same proposal
that was put last time which
um would be the most straightforward
thing to do but is that legitimate in
the circumstances
through chairman um the application
hasn't been determined so it still would
have to have a resolution
by the committee um right the
obviously the recommendation for refusal
stands terminal that's fallen but you
know
that's what the officers have so it
would still need a reason for approval
um and my advice would be that i'll see
members
she had a resolution last time if they
are happy
that's still their thought process now
obviously i would just advise that they
would
add to it a point around the uh
new material consideration that it
didn't consider to
uh outcome outweigh the consideration
but um unless
at the very beginning or can we build on
them when we had last time i think
we're just the clarity members i don't
know if i've ever made this quite clear
there's a big difference between reasons
for proven reasons to refusal
where uh refusal officers are much more
able to assist you in coming informing
them when there's case nomination for
approval
that it must be clear from a member of
public how the members have come to that
thought process and that's what the case
law is so when there is an approval you
probably think i'm not particularly
helpful but it's actually because the
law
stops that so without a debate here it's
quite hard to say too much because there
isn't anything on the table to
be ready to comment on but i hope that's
been some assistance thank you chairman
um yes thank you i was only looking for
process so
i think i will begin on the basis i
think somebody made an approval last
time
i can't look at everything at once
counselor fleming did you
make the proposal last time no i believe
it was
counselor white i made the
proposal last time um to
ask mr lee if we could borrow the
wording
from page 102 of the report from the
previous application
um paragraphs 5.8.6
down to 5.8.10 what was the page again
so that was page 102.
i just wanted mr lee's thoughts on that
like you confirm what sorry do you
chairman can you confirm the paragraph
numbers just i was scanning down and
then i
forgot ones i was looking at so it was
my previous application
5.8.6 down to 5.8.10
i was wondering whether that wording
would be helpful
sorry for clarity what page is this
because
page 102 102. sorry i've gone too far
get there
i don't know what you're looking at jane
um yes
still your chairman obviously that's the
uh balance of uh
the tilted balance position
that obviously we have to go through now
we don't have a five-year land supply
sorry we don't have councillor miss
white to repeat her proposal so i think
we should begin at the beginning
um
so i am here but i can't propose because
i missed the start of this article
and because of my bad accident driving
home so i've been stuck on the motorway
for two hours i apologize
i'm sorry silly it is good to see you um
okay so i think we had better go back to
the beginning
and come up with some words please
on relation to councillor fleming's
point um
obviously members
shouldn't advise ever just for one of
the better phrase cut and paste from
a previous report application and
obviously as members will know from
reading the reports officers of reports
are quite similar because
you know the terminology the planning
language etc is
you know repetitive for one of the
better phrases i know members sometimes
get frustrated their reasons for
how similar they are um so it's not a
case of saying that the points within
that
sections aren't relevant but i wouldn't
necessarily expect a full tilted balance
from members and i would
wouldn't encourage members just to say
we would like to use something from a
previous report as a clear
no repetition members were to look to
that that may give them some guidance
thank you thank you council
ms white actually proposing application
be approved
reasons relating to the lack of a
five-year housing land supply and that
the
applicants that address the immunity
space which haven't previously
met the council's requirements
the conditions relating to the approval
will be delegated to offices in
consultation with the chairman of the
committee and the ward members
um i think if we could delegate any
conditions
that would be good but can we have some
word for the rest of it please
somebody anybody counselor
fleming you have your hand up
thank you chair um so the wording
um i think that it's
if we could tack on to what we had
before that the
um application is compliant with
h4 effective use of land
essays settlement boundaries and growth
the reuse of redundant
or disused buildings that would lead to
the enhancement to the immediate
setting how is that
okay i've got council of jarvis
chairman i was only going to make a
point i was only going to make a point
we got the minutes in front of us
obviously
from the last
we have and that's what i just read from
yeah you're right we do
and that wasn't yeah that's what miss
white that is what miss white
says but you know we're beginning at the
beginning so
you have something to offer that would
be good thank you
if i might say challenge just trying to
assist uh uh
councillor fleming there i mean i think
uh what we were being guided on was
you know using the same perhaps the same
phrase we used last time but adding
that we've this time considered the
material
uh consideration material factor
presented by officers
but on balance that we've um uh
we've uh decided still that it doesn't
that
that the harm isn't outweighed um you
know by
by by sort of that proposal so i think
we just we've got to put in some
reference
clearly to the new material we have to
put that in
clearly we do but what we can't say is
let's say what we said last time we have
to know what we said last time
yeah well i think we said
um uh hear what you i hear what you're
saying but we've got to get the right
wording it has to be part of the
proposal and i need someone to make it
and someone to second it and if we can
get that part
that would be great thank you yeah
thank you for your input counseling i
mean you are right
i'm happy to propose that the
application be approved contrary to the
officer's recommendation
but the reasons relating to the lack of
a five-year
housing land supply the applicant has
addressed
the amenity space not meeting the
council's requirement
and that's what we said last time i have
to say
i think i'd have before you do that i
just want to add having taken into
account
the further material considerations
presented to council
i mean we should add something into that
effect we've all considered those
factors
and weighed it up so would that be okay
chairman i don't mean to steal
council of flaming thunder there no no
wasn't demanding anyone in particular do
it i'm just
grateful thank you um
i think i heard counselor key seconding
right well are you seconding councillor
jarvis's proposal
including the bit he put at the end
about um taking into account this latest
piece of information
i certainly will do that a second okay
right that is counselor joshua's
proposal
um is that clear enough
mrs fuller we did go round and round a
bit on that one
it sounded it sounded clear enough when
we got there but then are you
are you happy with that can we put it
can we put that to the vote please
yes chairman so we are voting to approve
the application
contrary to the officer's recommendation
members i'll take the vote starting with
councillor durham please
you thank you i'll abstain on this thank
you thank you
councillor mrs fleming paul thank you
katie
thank you councillor jarvis
paul thank you katie thank you
councillor keys
four plus cody thank you councillor
morley
thank you councillor four
thank you councillor mrs thompson
against thank you chairman
that is fought for one against and two
abstentions
yeah and i can't vote no and miss white
can't vote so
thank you um mr lee
i believe i could say in there somewhere
um delegating the conditions yep that
for you gemini i did know you saying
that just for clarity i just wanted to
double check that members were aware of
that and there's lots of nod in head so
yeah i think that's
lots and lots yeah right so we've got
don't take too long don't take too long
officer lee
hopefully there won't be any more appeal
decisions
right um i believe we're nearly there
members uh item eight on the agenda
uh next and i believe last planning
application is willow bank for heathcote
working bishops
um i will call on the office for the
moment to present the
item and we do have two submissions
three submissions
yeah three submissions from members of
the public so um
oh mr lee your hand is up did you
mean legacy hand
that's not a leg it's a hand
no that wasn't coming okay off we go
please officers report
thank you chair planning permission is
sought for a flat roof dormer to the
rear roof slope of the hose dwelling
with the juliet balcony and changes to
the fenestration of the rear elevation
the proposal includes an extension to
the existing garage
and alterations to the front elevation
which comprises of new fenestration
glazing an alteration to the existing
front dormer
and a roof light together with the
redesign of the front steps and front
door
the driveway will be renovated and new
decking and paving will be added to the
rear garden setting
the application site is situated to the
southeastern side of heathgate
which is a cul-de-sac the site consists
of a two-story detached dwelling
with a detached double garage to the
front the surrounding area is
residential in nature with dwellings of
similar scale but varying
appearance the use of contrasting
materials including cladding
is also present within the immediate
street scene
here are the existing and proposed block
plans
here is a secondary proposed block plan
you will note the footprint of the host
dwelling remains largely unaltered
here are the existing elevations of the
host dwelling
here are the proposed elevations of the
dwelling it should be noted that the
alterations in addition to the front
elevation
are likely to be within the sorry the
tolerance allowed for permitted
development legislation
the proposed dormer to the rear is also
of a size that could be built under
permitted development rights
with the exception of materials this
fallback position should be a material
consideration when determining
the application here are the existing
floor plans
here are the proposed floor plans
here are the existing and proposed
garage floor plans
sorry the diagrams aren't changing for
me at any rate this past oh they're not
as far as souls you know that might be
my internet connection i just thought i
better mention it in case
anyone else is inside they are changing
chairman
okay sorry about that then it's just my
internets too so
thank you okay sorry
here are the existing and proposed
garage elevation plans
here are some photographs of the
surrounding street scene
the first photograph is of a dwelling
two doors down from the application site
you will note the use of cladding on the
front elevation the photograph to the
top right shows further examples of
cladding within the wider locality
here are the photographs of the front of
the application site
note in the garage
here are some photographs of the rear of
the application site
including the rear southeast boundaries
objections to the flat roof door have
been received from neighbouring
occupiers regarding neighbouring
immunity
and in particular overlooking this
photograph was taken at first floor
level which has views
into the garden and habitual room to the
rear of number one heathgate
whilst the council considers there would
be a certain level of overlooking
it does not consider that the degree of
overlooking would be materially greater
than what exists on site at present
as can be seen through this photograph
furthermore
as suggested previously the proposed
dormer and juliet balcony are likely to
largely benefit from permitted
development rights
whereby the applicant could undertake
similar works without the need for
planning permission
when assessing if an application falls
within permitted development
the outlook of neighbouring occupiers is
not a consideration for this type of
development
there is also a significant uh degree of
separation of 40 meters from the
dwelling to the southeast
and it is not considered that the
development would give rise to any
material
overlooking to this occupier here are
some photographs showing the fleeting
views of the application site from
wellins
it is considered that development by
reason of its scale and design
on balance would not harm the character
or appearance of the host dwelling or
the locality
whilst that whilst there are views of
some neighboring amenities space
it is not considered that the degree of
overlooking would be material great
materially greater than what exists on
the site at present
and regards should be had to the full
back position of permitted development
rights
which is a material consideration when
determining the application
furthermore it is not considered that
the development would impact upon car
parking provisions
or private community space at the site
and therefore the development in is
accordance with policies d1
h4 and t2 of the local development plan
and is recommended for approval
finally by way of verbal members update
please be advised that policy
h1 as mentioned in the conclusion of the
officer report
should be policy h4 and one was an
administrative error thank you
right thank you um
well we will move on to our first public
participant
who is karen faith mr mrs faith can we
just check we can hear and see you okay
yes hello good evening uh hello i can
hear you i can't
yes i think i can see you yes here we go
thank you very much
um you have two minutes from when you
begin to speak so um
make yourself ready and off you go thank
you thank you
this roof design is not a typical dormer
window but a large extrusive patio door
with balcony
occupying two-thirds of the roof space
adding mass and bulk which modifications
have not addressed it contravenes the
local development plan
and permitted development as it's not
appropriate to the locality
this is not a small terraced house in an
urban area
or a property with views it's an
established area of similar detached
homes
in a historic village the materials used
should be similar to those on the
existing dwelling in molten's
own report it is admitted that the
materials still don't comply with local
pd
and is of limited architectural merit so
it's unclear why approval is recommended
impact on neighbouring properties please
see
the supplied photographs the development
should not harm appearance or carriage
of the host dwelling or locality
however it totally impacts on the
amenities and privacy of nearby houses
the architectural style should be
appropriate regarding height size form
orientation
but this design is high bulky obtrusive
and overlooks our bedroom the
development should have regard to
location and enhance
the surrounding areas this roof window
does nothing to enhance the area
and is detrimental to nearby properties
overlooking is stated that being no
greater than currently exists
not true a present privacy into our
bedrooms is not an issue
however such a large window at roof
level would look
down into our master bedroom this
sliding door with balcony would allow an
extended outlook
beyond the framework it stated that this
plan is within pd
but at the same time is admitted it does
not comply
with pd rules therefore this approach is
inconsistent
modern planning would be disregarding
its own rules and setting a precedent
for patio doors and rooftops all over
the malden area
using any materials they choose thank
you
thank you thank you mr space um now i
invite council of wardrobe of wiccan
bishops parish councillor to read out
their submission
um councillor could we just check that
we can hear and see you okay
i'm here can you see me hear me
i heard you for a second oh yes now i
can see you as well yes thank you uh you
have two minutes from when you begin to
speak
so off you go when you're ready thank
you
yes ma'am as well have noted that
throughout the office's report the
phrase on bands is used
this is not a clear-cut decision and it
is submitted that the officer should
have given greater weight
to the objections raised by the parish
council and local residents
parish council remains of the view that
this application should be refused for
the following reasons
the real part of the proposed
development does not meet the criteria
within policy d1 of the ldp
in particular items 1 a b and 4.
the officer accepts in para528 that the
dormer is relatively large with limited
architectural merit
taken with the following points the
balance should have fallen to refusal
para528 says that on balance
the rear doorman would not have a
detrimental impact on the locality
by implication therefore there is some
impact the officer has decided
no detriment could have gone to the
opposite view
in five to eight the officer accepted
the materials proposed would not be
acceptable under permitted development
rights
they should therefore be a reason for
refusal now
the proposed extruding external frame to
the dormer
would be an unacceptable device to
overcome
an accepted detrimental impact on
neighboring properties
particularly one heath gate it would be
in congress set against the rear
elevation as a whole
paris five three seven and five three
nine
should not argue that because there are
windows at the first story
additional windows to a second story
would not create
materially greater or a material
increase
in overlooking an additional story in
the
roof line would inevitably create
additional overlooking from a higher
vantage point
the additional story with full length
windows and the juliet balcony
would create an unacceptable degree of
overlooking to properties of the rearing
wellings
and the property to the site at one
heath gate
british council draws members attention
to the photographs submitted
by residents that show the overlooking
impact of the proposed development
thank you thank you thank you councillor
right that third submission is from mr
luca arno the agent i hope i've
pronounced you correctly
so can we just check we can hear and see
you
hello i can hear you
can you hear me i can hear you can you
turn your ah yes yes i can hear answer
you now
um so you have two minutes from when you
begin to speak so just
make yourself comfortable and off you go
thank you thanks very much
i we submit this project uh for the
first time on the
on july 2020 and
the planning received a few objections
from neighbors based on breaching
preaching of privacy we responded to
this matter by issuing a
series of documents demonstrating the
project didn't breach
any of the local development plan
policies
all the documents were attached to the
second submission
obviously before we moved for a second
application
we booked a pre-application meeting
held on the 19th of november 2020
and during this opener proactive
discussion uh the officer suggested a
few amendments
to make the submission compliant with
local policies and viable for approval
regarding the bulk of the rear extension
the report of the pre-application state
has discussed in our meeting the
previous application in the property was
refused due to the scale design
and bulk of the rear extension at the
property
which was considered to be unsympathetic
element with the street scene to the
detriment of the character
and the appearance of the host dwelling
the current proposal is so to reduce the
overall scale
uh by proposing a real dormer with the
roof slope of the property instead of
two-story extension
uh this amendment will be welcome
and it's my opinion that will be
considered
or not to be in congress feet of the
property given the subservient
design and appearance in relation to the
main house
then when it comes to the breach of
privacy the report states
as the dormer will be sight within the
roof of the host dwelling it is not
considered that the proposed real dormer
will cause any
overshadowing or other dominance to the
neighboring occupiers
although there will be additional
windows to the second floor
due to sufficient separation distances
between the properties it is not
considered
that the proposed development will cause
any overlooking
then is material greater than what
currently exists
as there are existing first floor
windows with similar
outlook so the project was amended
taking on board the pre-application
meeting guidelines and submitted again
on the 14th of december 2020.
uh currently the submission has four
timer i think we're out of time mr oh no
i'm sorry i have to stop
joe okay sorry just to finish up uh my
clients are also where the last
project falls within the boundaries of
permit development
stop really does mean stop thank you um
right councillor jarvis i do have you
first but i need to put the
recommendation
first which is that the planning
application for
willowbank heathgate we can bishops be
approved for the reasons detailed in
section eight of this report
uh does anyone wish to second that
motion because happy to second term
oh okay right thank you councillor
darren seconds it comparing your mind as
always that doesn't obligate him to vote
for it
thank you chairman um well we've heard a
lot of the comments there from
the neighbor i think is from number one
and we've heard comments obviously from
wiccan bishops parish council
they really want to go through all of
those points again so i'll just sort of
pick
i think one of the most material points
um i think there is a lot of reference
to balance
and and sort of balance of neighborly
and balance of intrusion
i mean i think the really key points are
that um
the comment has been made that uh that
that it's not a materially different
view
i visited uh uh the property with uh due
care
social distancing and i mean this is a
whole story higher
this is a whole story higher uh if
you're a whole story higher
and you look uh down you can see clearly
you have a completely different view so
i just refute that
uh a sort of conclusion uh i think
anybody can see
that that is a completely different view
and it's a difference that makes a
difference
it's not just that it's uh on the next
story up we all know that if you're
looking straight across
at somebody else's bedroom if you're at
the same level
you can't really see much but if you're
a whole story up
that's a completely different matter so
i think this is a difference that makes
a difference
in terms of the intrusion nature in
terms of the line of sight
and i think the other point i would want
to emphasize
is there's reference made to it being
not uncommon i'd like the officers to
comment a bit and come back on that if
they might
not uncommon um well i i i
i think there's this that snippet of a
few bits of wood
on one of the houses in heathcake which
seems to sort of
allege to support the fact that this
sort of development is not
uncommon i can guarantee you there are
no other
developments like this in heathgate and
a few bits of boarding on one of the
properties doesn't mean
that this sort of development is uh is
is sort of
uh that it and it's anywhere else in
heathcote and those photos that you were
shown there
of other properties in the near vicinity
well look you know those are other
streets of course
there are other streets with lots of
different properties wellands which is
where those photographs were taken
is a street that's made up of lots of
different types of properties
and beautiful in its own way but it's
not heathgate
where there are no other properties with
this sort of development so it is
decidedly against the street seat
and i think that's a point which has to
be mentioned the other points have been
mentioned already
regarding the size and bulk which
anybody that can see the plan
and has had the advantage of seeing some
of the photographs
would agree look some well it is clearly
quite
daunting a daunting extension of course
to one of the properties to one side it
doesn't overlook
but it has to be surely considered is it
intrusive on all of the properties
nearby
and on the other side of that
development number one it
it does look as if chairman it is pretty
intrusive we've heard the comments about
material
uh that and we've i've made reference to
the fact
there really really is not a similar
sort of use of material
in that street i think those are the
main points i'd like to make
sure and i'm very obviously keen to hear
what other councils have got to say
so that obviously one can make a
balanced decision thank you
thank you um before i move on to any
other members i'm just going to give
warning to the officers probably mr lee
um i
would like a bit more quite a lot more
clarity actually on exactly what the
fallback position
could be uh in the meantime i think
i've got councillor civil followed by
councillor white followed by councillor
durham if you agree with but i'm pretty
sure councilman siddal was next so let's
start with you please
thank you very much chairman uh one of
my questions is is
yeah there's a lot of the officers there
and the agent they were talking about
that a lot of this
is would be in within permitted
development
so i've got a question as to
what we're actually deciding on and what
would be allowed without a planning
application
yeah that's one of my concerns are there
things that
yeah if the if the applicant brought
this forward that they could do it
without planning permission so why
why is it here in terms of
the uh the the
structure into the roof uh
the fenestration on that it's just
dreadful
absolutely dreadful uh and i wouldn't
want that
in a house next to me yeah yeah i can
understand someone wanting to go into
lost space and i can understand someone
wanting to increase their their
accommodation by doing that
but it's that big huge
you know patio door thing on top of a
house
um and that is a huge
invasion of privacy and an imposition
on the surrounding properties so i can
see the reason that someone might want
to go into the law space and and that's
fine
but but why does it have to be designed
in that particular way
it's totally unsympathetic to the
surrounding properties
and as councillor jarvis has said yeah i
know we can bishops
well i know he's gay quite well there
isn't really any other property like
that that's been developed in that way
on heathgate um so there's the my
the question is is is why is it here
where what would be permitted and
and yeah in terms of those of those
questions can be answered
and yeah surely if they could change the
the fenestration the the type of
window so that it doesn't cause such a
invasion of the surrounding properties
if it is going to go ahead
thank you well we'll see thank you
councillor civil um i think well your
question largely matches mine but you
know if someone wants to apply for
planning permission
we get to see it um that's just how it
is
uh i believe i have mr councillor white
next
thank you madam chairman when i have to
say i'm going to come to a country
view to the other members um although it
might not be
my cup of tea um plenty of people have
done extensions that i haven't liked
over the years that i've supported
because something they want to do
families are stuck at home and i think
it was something they do this summer
that would be um good for them
and i think when you live in an area
with lots of houses there's always going
to be a certain
amount of overlooking and i don't think
this is going to be very much worse than
what there
already is and i don't imagine they'll
want people looking in their bedrooms i
would think they'd have curtains up
anyway so i actually don't have a
problem
and i'm all for supporting people who
want to extend their houses so i think
the officers have actually got this one
right
okay thank you councillor darren
um i i'm afraid i have to agree with
my fellow ward member councillor jarvis
who made a very eloquent
summary of the situation and indeed
councillor siddal
um i'm not going to go on for too much
longer but
you know the piece i object to more than
anything else is
is the carbuncle on the back roof and
that's exactly what it is
you know a flat roof and pat
effectively patio doors on the juliet
balcony i mean aesthetically
it's horrific ignoring the overlooking
and everything else so
um i i'm i'm supporting
uh my fellow ward member um the adjacent
dwelling and the parish council thank
you
okay um mr lee could we um
could we please have an explanation of
what differences there would have to be
in order to bring it forward under
permitted development
anybody thank you chairman um
uh ms martin can you pull up the
elevations it might be easier if i just
show that
but i just
okay um my understanding if i'm correct
and that was miles might be able to quit
me if i'm wrong or i think
miss johnson's got his hand up to us
maybe he's got something to say that is
that
the door mark is around 35 meters
squared which would fall within the
permitted development allowance the
distance set back from the bridge of
knee the eave is acceptable within the
permitted development allowance
and matters such as the fenestration and
not consideration under
pds in the aesthetics of the development
the only reason that the
dormer does not require so it does
require planning permission and
therefore is before members is because
of the choice of materials if the
members
of the members
um look to have concerns with
application they need to be conscious
that
if this application was if this if the
applicant decided to build this dormer
with out of materials that match or
similar to the main dwelling
it wouldn't actually require planning
permission and wouldn't be before
members
i hope i finished your question thank
you chad
um uh yes yes you have
um thank you um i've got councillor
darren's hand up
and one i don't it's one of 13. so um
can you speak up if you're not
councillor darren you've got your hand
up please
no it's an old one thank you i'm an old
hand and it's gone
it's um
i i can't tell it's you so please go
ahead no that's okay
i was just gonna add on to what mr lee
was saying there is actually very little
um
in this application um that cannot be
carried out under permitted development
um the the roof extension
is within committed development limits
a roof extension on a detached dwelling
can be up to 50 cubit meters
in area this is at least 10 to 15
cubic meters below permitted development
there is no control
over having windows
slide indoors as you can see there a
juliet balcony which is really just a
rail or it could be a glazed panel
in this case in front of the doors as
long as it doesn't protrude beyond the
face
of the dormer is permitted development
um the timber cladding around the rest
of the building
as long as it's not within a
conservation area one can
clad a dwelling house um
the timber clad into the
fro i mean the the wall at the front is
of the same height any change to any
material is within that
furthermore it is set significantly back
from
the uh public highway so therefore any
walls up to two meters in height
uh can be built on the front the
glazing above the doorway can also be
carried on
under permitted development the only
restriction on glazing
in terms of permitted development would
be windows above ground floor level
in the side and they would need to be
obscured
the front and the rear there is no
control in that sense
the significant difference between this
application and the previous one was
that there was
something which and i suppose pick up on
council dara's
comments would have probably been
considered a car bonker
which was effectively a two-storey
timber structure
sort of tagged on to the back now that's
where permission would have been
required it's extended beyond the
the face of the building including
breaking the eaves of the dormer
which obviously would have nullified any
permitted development rights so really
there's significant amounts
that can be carried out under permitted
development and to be honest
you know when we consider these
applications i mean i raise the
questions with my colleague miss marsden
why don't they just um
clad the dormer uh in mater materials to
match
the rest of the roof and off they'd go
and to be honest that could be the
position
um the applicants here are quite um
adamant that they want timber that's
their choice and they've made a planning
application for that
so hopefully that clears up the matter
of what's in front of us
thank you very much it does for me thank
you um
i have councillor jarvis but also
councilman hasn't spoken yet so
can i hold you to some up at the end
councillor jarvis
right thank you thank you council jobs
councillor morley yeah yeah thank you
chair so
am i writing thinking they could do it
anyway but under this
planning application it's guidance under
the officers and the planners
is that correct uh i think the long and
the short and i'm sure an officer will
jump in if i'm
wrong i hope so um that basically the
only thing they need permission for is
planning
on the dormer part
if we don't grant it they can do exactly
the same thing but they can't put timber
padding on that which is the thing they
particularly like
okay i have another answer let's answer
my questions
thank you thank you so councilman jarvis
yeah thank you chairman and thank you
for the officers for uh elaborating on a
number of
points there um i still think i mean i
have to say i'm quite shocked
that uh something of that magnitude can
be built under permitted development i'm
sure i'm not the only one that shot
that and i just want to emphasize that
you there are no other
uh carb uncles who use counselor
durham's work
in heathcote uh and uh you know
it seems to me that i'm shocked that the
intrusion of privacy issue
um which you know we all care so much
about isn't
a factor under permitted development
that's what we're being saying
i did ask a question though for officers
to come back on yeah we're showing lots
of photographs of
other properties uh in the in that it's
not
uncommon and could officers just clarify
that point for me whilst i'm summing up
i mean
it is uh there is nothing else like this
in heathcote
i think to extend the phrase uncommon to
include
other streets in the village is somewhat
stretching a point in the argument
that's my point
chairman and i would uh i would like
officers to uh
clarify that all of the shots were in
fact of
other streets in wicked bishops not
heathcape except for the very small
amount of wood which you probably
couldn't spot
on one property in heathcote you know a
few strips of wood i don't think that
constitutes a similar
oh mr johnson thank you you're going to
watch um
yeah um i do appreciate what counselor
jarvis means in terms of uncommon
sometimes the use of
language and planning isn't exactly the
same as if you would use it
um in your normal power land
we say uncommon as taking more than just
what's next door or even one or two
properties down
or the whole street but i mean i think
walking around the corner
which is within the vicinity um in
planner's point of view would fall
within the
not uncommon yeah it's not as if there
is no wood within that area
so that i mean that's the best i can say
in terms of explaining the word
uncommon thank you chairman
thank you thank you thank you for making
that
point um i have to say i found that
quite surprising and somewhat
disappointing but thank you for taking
the opportunity to explain it
um so i think uh chairman i think i've
done my summing up but
i still feel it's an oversized uh
extension that looks um
that that is in the loft which will
cause um
you know material factors uh in terms of
looking into other people's
uh bedrooms which i think is awful um
you know we've heard the points on
balance than
of what might otherwise go through as
permitted development but what's before
us tonight is an application
uh and i think i've certainly tried to
weigh things up here
and i've heard a number of points that
have been made
and i think on balance i still am not
not in favor of this application having
heard the debate i think if this
application is approved it says sorry
so it will be a sorry precedent for what
would potentially happen to
a wonderful street i think that's my
summing up chairman
okay thank you
right that's the last hand i think um
to speak towards councillor jarvis so we
are still going to vote first
we're going to vote on the
recommendation to approve this uh so
mrs fuller could we have a take a vote
please
yes chairman so members we are going to
vote for approval of the application in
line with the officer's
recommendation members if you could
state four against or abstain
starting with councillor durham please
thank you i hear what's been said
about pdr but this is an application
and uh i'm not happy with it and i think
we should send a message that we're not
happy with it
so i'm against the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you councillor mrs fleming
abstain katie thank you thank you
councillor jarvis
i'm against thank you councillor keys
i'm against boys thank you
councillor morley against
thank you councillor four
thank you mrs thompson
i'm against actually for the same reason
as councillor darren i mean pd it may
have to be
so could we have the scores on those uh
councillor miss white
first thank you oh sorry sorry thank you
german that is two four five against and
one abstention
okay thank you so the recommendation
balls could i have a proposal please i'm
looking at councillor jarvis
but anyway
i think um the proposal would be to um
to refuse uh based on the
bulk of the application and the
intrusive nature of the views
in terms of um affecting the immunity of
the local properties
and the materials used i think they
would be
um and the fact that it's um i would
like to say the fact that it's not uh
not a common development and therefore
it's against the street scene
sure within that there are sufficient
reasons many other councils want to chip
in and assist
do you feel free
not all at once please because i'm
losing track um
jarvis you're happy with that
and council yes i think i'd like all
four in there
if um if that's okay it's fine cattle
morning
it is totally out of proportion the
proportion
not right does it with that class yes
that's his own size and bulk
i think that comes under design
um i'm just going to bring mr lee in
because
i don't want to come up with any
objections that
you know are going to cause us a problem
if we go to appeal
so mr lee
thank you chairman um it's an
interesting
point because you know the
dormer as proposed with exceptional
materials can be built
um without the need for planning
permission um which is a material
situation
is the full back position and it's up to
the decision maker to consider
how the weight that they give that
decision they that fall back position
case law is clear in the stringer case
that that is up to them as long as it's
not an unreasonable decision
um but members need to balance the two
facts that actually what is the harm
materially between a the proposed public
development
dormer and the sorry the proposed
applications dorma and the
application that could be constructed
under committee development and my
advice would be
to you know that members have discussed
some of the points that the difference
is and
would really be to whilst they can
acknowledge the points such as bulk
scale etc that you know if it is the
provision of the material this
exacerbates that harm
and that's the that's the difference and
it takes it over
there or means that it doesn't get over
the boundary of of the
you know the problem of whether or not
it should be going planning efficient so
my advice would be for members to really
look at
the differences between what could be
done as planned permission what
without needing permission what can be
and highlight that alongside the
concerns around the bulk and scale thank
you chairman
okay thank you um while we digest that
council of darwin
well chairman i think given that we
the the the applicant can exercise pdr
almost immediately i very much doubt
that he'll wait
what will effectively be maybe even 12
months for an appeal decision
but i i do take um officer lee's um
comments but i'm i'm happy with the
reasons given to be quite honest and i
don't think we should prolong this too
much longer thank you
fair enough so council jarvis if having
heard that you're still happy with your
proposal that
you could just run us through it again
so we know that
i think we i think i think i am i mean i
you know i think at the end of the day i
have heard officer lee's comments there
and obviously to uh
welcome his input um and i think we will
certainly include the materials
aspect but i think the four points that
i've raised i think
i would want put in which is um due to
the um
due to the sort of bulky design um the
lack of amenity i either view on the
neighbours
um the materials being used and the fact
that it's not in keeping
or with the street scene would be my
four points and i think i'd write them
all in
yeah fine fine your proposal i'm just
checking uh councillor durham you were
going to second that i believe i'm happy
to chairman yeah he's happy to write so
we have a proposal julie seconded
um this is can we do the
delegate the conditions such as there
are which isn't going to be much
happy to do that sorry as you will come
on
come on there are no conditions correct
there are no conditions i am talking
rubbish mrs fuller could we take a vote
please
yes chairman so we are voting to refuse
the application
contrary to the officer's recommendation
starting with councillor durham please
thank you councillor mrs fleming abstain
katie thank you
thank you councillor jarvis oh
thank you katie thank you cut the keys
four close cody thank you councillor
morley
paul thank you councillor
abstain councillor mrs thompson
paul thank you and councillor miss white
against queue chairman that is five
four one against and two abstentions
okay so um we've ended up with uh
willow bank is um has been used
in line with the proposal which was made
seconded and voted on
uh so we are now at item nine any other
items of business the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent and you'll
be delighted to hear there are none
so members thank you for your
contributions to [ __ ]
sorry check i just there is something i
just like to raise that's all right
members oh i'm sorry yes mr lee sorry
yes
sorry bubba's too uh i'll try not to
keep them eating any longer they need to
it's just that actually
um with moscone's farm there was
actually
um suggested conditions as what had been
drafted by officers
on the report that went before members
so
we would suggest that rather than
actually delegating the conditions that
would then have to be circulated
they members should grant subject to
those conditions that were detailed on
the report on page nine through to
109 through two 111 just to make
process a little bit quicker and then
for councillor jarvis's
uh comfort we hope to get the decision
that's out tomorrow um
i'm absolutely fine with that mrs
fleming yeah
happy with that thank you everybody
happy with that
everybody's happy thank you for your
intervention mr lee that
very helpful uh right i'll go back to
closing the meeting
members thank you for your contributions
thank you officers
thank you for everyone who attended i
will now draw the meeting to a close
at 2018 which is pretty good for us
um thank you very much as the meeting is
now closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussion on this forum
and please leave the meeting promptly
thank you thank you everyone
thank you